[light music]
♪ ♪
Once a month, when the moon
is a waxing gibbous
we have to have procreation sex
with our dumb husbands.
(Beatrice)
First, we have to do
a ritual dance
to ensure
we have a male heir.
This world does not need
more girls.
[wild tribal music]
I don't know why we took all
that land from the Indians
if we're just going to act
like them.
I'd rather give birth to a goat
than another girl.
At least a goat might have
a good idea once in a while.
[screams]
I'm ready.
Having sex with Albert is
like being penetrated
by a runny egg.
[sighs]
[grunts]
Yeah, there it is.
Well, having sex with Victor is
like drowning under a quilt
moistened by halitosis.
(Victor)
All right, here we go.
Oh.
[groans]
Oh, Victor. Oh, Victor.
Make your voice really deep.
[deep voice]
Oh, Victor.
Uh...
[laughs]
That's it. That's it, yes.
Victor. Oh, God.
Okay. Good.
Aah!
[hums]
There and...
- [groans]
- Ah.
Done.
Ouch. Ow. Ow.
Good.
How did he get on the bed?
I'm so surprised that he's here.
What? You're fired!
Don't you come in when
I'm making love to my wife!